every day in this country
families are forced to make impossible
choices when it comes to their health
care
like kimberly who said
there was times i had to choose between
my food
and my pills it wasn't luxury stuff
because i didn't make that much
it was like can i get shampoo or
conditioner
things you take for granted and debbie
who said you put your medicine in one
hand
your living costs in the other okay
well what am i going to do am i going to
get my medicine
or am i going to pay my bills well i
can't live without my medicine
but i can't live if i don't pay my bills
10 000 people die every month in this
country
because they don't take the medicine
that they need
more people die from not taking
medications
then opioid overdoses and car accidents
combined but you can't take medicine
if you can't afford it today the average
household
spends three thousand dollars a year on
medications
about a third of folks who are uninsured
said that they stopped taking medicine
as prescribed
because of cost even folks with
insurance
if they make under 35 000 a year
half of them report skipping the
medications
if their insurance doesn't cover it so
there are 10
million adults like kimberly and like
debbie
who are forced to make impossible
choices
every day we all know that prescription
drug prices
are too high and our health care system
that makes some folks uninsured and
other folks
underinsured doesn't prioritize
people who need access now and need
medications
now 10 million it's a big number
but it's also a solvable number because
there's also
10 billion dollars of perfectly good
unused medication that goes to waste
so this is an injustice on two sides
people not getting the medicine that
they need to survive
and to thrive in that very same
medication
being sent to a medical waste
incinerator to be destroyed
this waste is unconscionable but it also
offers an opportunity
i started serum a not-for-profit
technology company with my co-founders
adam and george
to turn discarded medications into a
lifeline
just like the medications in this
warehouse
we may not be able to fix all the ways
in which our health care system is
failing us
but we can fix this one
medications come from manufacturers and
wholesalers who have safety stock
and when it's short-dated they destroy
it it also comes from healthcare
facilities
like hospitals pharmacies and nursing
homes
who end up with surplus when a patient
stops taking medication
or when they pass away we can use this
untapped source of medications to supply
all 10 million people who need
medications
and we can do this today serum gets
surplus medications
by putting recycling bins into these
hundreds of facilities
that have surplus they fill the bin and
when the box is full
serum initiates a courier pickup to pick
up that medication
and we handle the shipping the tracking
the manifests and the tax receipt
medicine donors
want to donate because it's actually
cheaper and easier
than the highly regulated medicine
destruction process
and there are strong tax incentives to
actually donate
we then deliver those donated
medications
to people who need it a new prescription
comes in
and our platform matches that patient
need
with the inventory that's available our
platform then generates a warehouse pick
list
the medications are picked and the
prescriptions filled
we are building the 21st century
pharmacy experience
that low-income families deserve
patients can register in under five
minutes and have access to over
500 different medications a stable list
of medications for everything from heart
disease
to mental health conditions actually
representing
over 75 percent of all prescriptions
prescribed in the united states today we
also partner
with a network of doctors nurses and
case managers
at community health centers and free
clinics that refer
patients to the service we make it as
easy for these health care providers
to have a prescription filled with
donated medications
as it is to send a prescription to a
local pharmacy
and patients can pick up medications on
site at one of our partners
or have medications delivered directly
to their home
by circumventing the traditional supply
chain
we're able to offer flat transparent
pricing
about two dollars for a month's supply
of most medications
and that allows a predictable affordable
price
that folks can actually budget for
we've already supplied enough medication
for 150
000 people but we can do more
our goal is to reach 1 million people
with approaching a billion dollars of
unused medicine
in the next five years scaling our
program to 12 states
at this scale we can actually cover
communities that are home
to 40 percent of the 10 million people
who lack consistent affordable access
our direct service to 1 million people
will drive price competition for so many
more
walmart launched one of the only price
innovations in pharmacy in 2006
by offering a limited list of
medications for a flat fee of four
dollars
this sparked incredible change it
sparked competitors to offer
other lists and price match guarantees
by targeting transparent affordable
medications
into these new states we can actually
drive
regional price competition that drives
down the prices
for entire low-income communities
our health care system is complex
it is daunting it feels impossible
to make headway but we can completely
reimagine medicine access
by using surplus medications as a beach
head
to force change into this multi-billion
dollar industry
we can create radical access to
medications
based on a fundamental belief that
people who live
in one of the wealthiest nations in the
world
can and should have access to medicine
that they need
to survive and to thrive
i do not pretend to have all the answers
to fix all of the problems in our health
care system
but getting medications to the millions
of people who need it
to live a healthy life saving medicine
to save lives that is something we can
do
today thank you